liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nach und
es ist nun schon mehr als ein jahr
dass wir in dieser pandemie leben mehr
ja das ist der größte teil meiner arbeit
als bundeskanzlerin der arbeit der
bundesregierung der des bundestages der
landesregierung der landtag der kreis
hagen vorbehalten mitte wieder eine
aufgabe zu tun hat unser land durch
diese katastrophe und wieder bessere
zeiten zu führen
seit dem autor barney stellen wir uns
allgemeinen haben gegen das hier los ist
eine mögliche nationale kraft das
schränkt die jenaer was um die jeden
alte wie junge und kinder stadt und land
politik verwaltung und wirtschaft kultur
sport kirchen unser aller leben und
zusammenleben
er ist ein jahr liebe immer erinnern
gelernt haben wieder dass wir jungs
funktioniert und was gegen das ist genau
das funktioniert lernen heißt nicht von
anfang an immer alles richtig zu machen
auch einschätzungen zu korrigieren so
wie wir es zum beispiel bei den
empfehlungen für das tragen von masken
getan haben aber gerade deswegen sage
ich auch wenn wir gerade eher
schwierigen phase stecken und viele
menschen das gefühl haben das wirklich
nicht mehr lange auszeit
gerade deswegen sage ich auch wir haben
in diesem jahr und der pandemie ein sehr
großes stück des so kämen die sind bei
uns gebracht
um dabei hatten und haben wir das ziel
unsere gesundheit ist unser
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
höchste belastung der menschen der
kapazitäten in den intensiv medizin
sie gab es und gibt es leider
und wir können unseren herzen und ärzten
und pflegerinnen und pflegern gar nicht
oft genug für alle ihren einsatz danken
aber immer das unseres
gesundheitssystems die konnten wir
vermeiden
gott sei dank der mit schweren folgen
einer infektion in klinik muss der
bekommt überall in deutschland die
versorgung wie er braucht
wir sehen an vielen orten der welt wie
wenig selbstverständlich diese aussage
ist und wir können gemeinsam froh
darüber sein
dabei weiß ich dass das was irgendwie
einsam im kampf gegen die ausbreitung
des virus erreicht haben einen hohen
preis gekostet hat und unverändert
kostet ich habe es keinen einzigen tag
was die notwendigen maßnahmen für jeden
bürger jede bürgerin bedeuten eine der
bundesrepublik so nie erlebte
zeitweilige gravierende einschränkung
der freiheit schwere persönliche
belastungen einsamkeit wirtschaftliche
sorgen
existenzängste das vergesse ich keinen
einzigen tag
alle maßnahmen sind gemäss den regeln
von demokratien beschlossen
das macht es rechtmäßig aber ich weiß
sehr wohl als demokratie sind wir auf
diese einschränkung keinen tag länger
aufrecht so als würde ich ihn aufzugeben
wenn ihre belohnung enthält und genau
das ist das ziel der unternehmung
ich weiß auch das 1000
[Applaus]
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren